At Disney's Animal Kingdom theme park Day
dawns for Africa's Mightiest Meat Eaters.
Alright, are you ready to shift 1.2 line on show?
Have a great day.
Three Majestic Lions
rule this savanna.
You normally see them walk
their whole perimeter and set mark
a lot of different things.
This is how lions communicate
not only with each other, but with other.
Lion prides in the wild
after they survey their surroundings.
Typically your hail
them vocalize to group.
Is that beautiful?
Right. Oh.
And that's pretty typical lion behavior.
That's how they announce themselves.
Kenzi is kind of got like a rasp
to her vocalization. Oh.
He likes to do a quick huff,
and then Dakari
is just big, loud and powerful.
And vocalizing
is one of my favorite things in the world.
I've worked with him for two years
and hearing that sound every day
just gives me goose bumps.
You'll see a lot of play behavior.
One of their favorite things to do
is spar and play with each other.
Our two sisters, Kinsey
and Kamari, really love to see
who can sneak up on the other first.
Oh, it's always been
one of my biggest goals to work
with these beautiful African carnivores.
And I have fallen in love with this pride.
Morning, Kamari.
How are you doing today?
You're having a good morning.
From this vantage point,
they can see the entire east.
Savannah, our Barnaba,
our water buck are coming out here.
We have our officer, Jaz.
They definitely get really hyped
when the ostrich comes soaring by.
But at the happiest place on earth
ahead, a network of moats and barriers
keeps predators and prey apart.
Right now we are introducing
some of our baby rhinos to the savannah.
Are you excited to see the baby
rhinos come out?
Oh, yeah.
We have Milo Ranger and their sister Logan
coming out every day.
These guys definitely keep a good,
watchful eye over the savannah
when all these babies are coming out
and exploring their new surroundings.
A healthy
lion needs more than just eye candy.
We get bored looking at the same stuff
every single day, so why wouldn't they?
They're all entering their teens, which is
the geriatric stage in a big cats life.
So we really need to see
how their range of motion is functioning,
just like when we get older.
Arthritis is a big problem
They need a hook term on a giraffe.
Yesterday we put some of those shavings
on that rock to replicate natural scents
that lions would smell in the wild
like a giraffe
just walk through their exhibit.
This is really cool to see her
pawing and clawing at that just like
she would be using those muscles
to hunt and forage in the wild. Oh.